[Music]
what's up guys i'm brianna and it's
tasty birthday
so we brought you some pretty special
cake recipes over the years so it's only
right
tasty's birthday cake be all types of
extra
that's why we're mashing together five
recipes
including our perfect chocolate chip
cookie recipe
let's make the ultimate five layer
cookie cake of your dreams
let's get started
we're starting with our perfect
chocolate chip cookie recipe which
starts with
browning one cup of butter and slowly
bringing this to a boil
once your butter is beautiful and brown
has a nice nutty
flavor and smell to it we want to pour
it in a measuring cup to let it cool
until we're ready to use it
on to the next we're going to sift
together our dry ingredients so we have
both of our flours ap and bread and then
our salt
and baking soda
sift away any lumps and now that's ready
now we're going to move this to the side
for later and move on to creaming our
next ingredient starting with our sugar
brown sugar espresso powder vanilla
and that beautifully golden brown
cascading butter you want to get
all of these brown bits out we worked
hard for that
they give us a nice flavor we want all
of them
scrape them out and then we mix
oh not yet hold up now
perfect so once it's lighter in color
you don't see any more melted butter
we're ready to move on and add our eggs
one egg and one egg yolk
and mix
all right our mix is nice and creamy we
don't want to over mix so
it's time to incorporate our flour one
third at a time
[Music]
i just want to grab a spatula and scrape
these sides down
she's ready mix in our chocolate chips
the star of the show the main reason
we're here
all right now i know this looks amazing
and probably smells even better but you
must resist the urge to eat this because
don't worry about it we're going to make
an edible cookie dough next
now that our dough has chilled out all
that's left to do is scoop
and bake i want a small cookie for
the sides of our cake so this little
scoop is perfect
our edible cookie dough recipe is an
adapted eggless version of the previous
recipe
and we're going to put this between each
and every
layer of our cake we're gonna start with
our brown butter
and our sugar and our brown sugar
and we'll mix
all right now we're gonna add in our
espresso powder
salt vanilla milk and
lastly we have our ap flour now we baked
this off in the oven for about
five minutes to kill any yucky harmful
bacteria
you never want to eat raw flour
just like last time we're gonna fold in
our chocolate chips
and chocolate chunks the good thing is
if this is too tempting not to eat
you can eat it this is safe to eat raw
that is the whole
reason we're making it all right this is
all folded in and incorporated so we're
gonna move it into our cake pans to
chill out
time to get colorful so we have our
buttercream
all ready to go the recipe is available
on tasty.com
out here dropping bars while we're
making our cake we're going to
liven ours up and tint it with pink food
coloring
and blue food coloring we've got one cup
of buttercream each
and mix with the spatula until well
combined it kind of looks
like cotton candy just as sweet has that
beautiful blue hue
say that five times fast because we're
five
oh she is a bright pink okay she did not
come to play
this just screams birthday to me i don't
see any more streaks of white in this
bowl so we're all good to go i'm gonna
get these in some piping bags and get
ready to go
it's finally time to assemble
it didn't get in the food we've got all
of our components ready to go
our buttercream our edible cookie dough
layers and our cake layers
these are vanilla cake and chocolate
cakes with chocolate chips in them
and these are tasty.co recipes you can
find the link below
to start add a dollop of buttercream to
your cake board and spread thin
and our first layer of cake top with
buttercream and spread evenly
not too much just enough to keep our
cookie dough in place
when we place that on top grab our first
disc
beautiful same thing
nice good thin even layer of buttercream
it's chocolate time time for our first
chocolate layer
same routine get your buttercream
time to speed up and get smooth
we're not looking for anything perfect
here just a nice good
foundation for our next layer to go on
top i'm sure you see it it's leaning
again and that's because it's getting a
little warm
every the layers are getting soft so i'm
going to work a little faster
get our last layer of vanilla cake on
top and
find some way to fit this in the fridge
because
it needs to cool and lock itself back
together
this is huge and i'm getting more
nervous as time passes
i'm going to scurry along and rush this
into the fridge so that it can chill and
set up
immediately
now it's time to move on to our ganache
we have stacks on stacks on stacks of
cake so it's only right
we bring a little drip with it too we
have our chocolate in a bowl
i'm going to pour some hot heavy cream
on top be careful when you do this don't
burn yourself so now we can stir
and mix our ganache like i said super
simple
we're gonna get it into our piping bag
because this is the
final component for our cake
now it's time to get a nice beautiful
finishing layer of buttercream
it's time to jazz this up now so let's
get started on our stripes
all right that's deep enough now it's
time to add our pink and blue
buttercream it's looking adorable so far
all this color is making it pop i'm
getting excited to see the final product
we're almost there i just want to smooth
this out
as carefully and cleanly as possible
to ensure we get those nice clean
stripes oh i hope they look good
i'm just letting the table do all the
work for me i'm not applying much
pressure
at all we've got stripes i'm happy
we're gonna place our perfect chocolate
chip cookies all around
the base of our cake slow and steady
kind of wins the race with the drip
when we're done with the edge we're
gonna move into the center and put the
ganache all over the cake just gonna
pipe some
cute little rosette guys on here
i'm ready to top it with our edible
dough balls that i rolled earlier
now time to deck out the top with our
perfect cookies
that's it we did it we're done it's over
this cake is finished tasty's ultimate
birthday cake
oh my god let me tell y'all this was a
challenge but we made it
we're here it's done now all that's left
is to slice this baby open and see
how it tastes on the inside
[Music]
[Music]
oh man delicious all right guys this was
the
ultimate five-layer cookie cake for
tasty's fifth birthday
so happy birthday tasty and too many
many more to come
so turn up tasty
hey go tasty it should burp go
tasty it's your birthday oh yes
[Music]
you